[MUSIC PLAYING]
VEST: Today, as we honor and
as we learn from Kofi Annan,
we take great pride
in the small role
that we played in his
education and in shaping
his early career.
But we also bear witness
to the importance
of maintaining the openness
of our universities
to foreign students,
scholars, and faculty.
We must guard, even in
these complicated times,
and protect this fundamental
American and academic value
and principle.
It is my privilege
and honor, once again,
to welcome to MIT the
Secretary-General of the United
Nations, His
Excellency, Kofi Annan.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNAN: Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much,
my dear friends.
President Vest, let me thank
you for those very warm and kind
words of introduction.
And Dean Schmalensee, I'm
really happy that I'm back here
with all of you at Sloan.
Distinguished faculty members
and students and dear friends,
it is indeed a pleasure
for me to be back here
and to join you today for
this anniversary celebration.
Over the course
of half a century,
Sloan School of Management
has built itself
into one of the world's
academic powerhouses.
I say world and not just
country because right
from the beginning,
Sloan looked well
beyond the confines
of this campus
and encouraged people
from many nations,
as we heard from the
president, to study here
and was eager to
find and advance
the cause of
international cooperation,
scholarly and otherwise.
Congratulations
on this milestone.
Three decades ago, I was
fortunate myself to become
part of the Sloan community.
And it is good to see so many
familiar faces since I've
been down here yesterday.
And an event like this
really brings back
memories of when I first came
here, what the place was like,
and where I myself was at
at that stage of my life.
I recall particular
that Sloan exposed me
to some very interesting work
in organizational culture
and psychology and
how to manage change.
That may sound like
jargon to most of you,
but I can assure
you that it came in
very handy at the United
Nations when I needed.
[LAUGHTER]
Back in 1982 when I was working
with the High Commissioner
for Refugees in
Geneva and we were
trying to grapple with the
crisis of the boat people,
I invited my good
friend Professor Schein
to come to Geneva
to help us improve
our internal communication
and to review our mission.
When we got there
and everybody came,
we thought we were going
to have a straightforward
discussion for one hour.
Three hours later, we were
all physically and emotionally
drained from what had
quickly turned out
to be a frank soul-searching
exercise for all of us
what it meant to be working for
the United Nations, what were
we trying to do with the
refugee crisis of the time,
and how best to get
different people
and people from nationalities
around the world
to work better together.
Some frustrations had been
bottled up obviously for years.
But once the
floodgates were open,
we found new ways forward,
and a truly new sense
of unity and purpose emerged.
This session was so successful
that I organized another one
in 1990 where Ed Schein
and Lester Thurow came
to talk to the group.
We gathered about
30 senior officials
from 26 different countries
to discuss similar issues,
and they all walked
away very enthusiastic.
I like to think that
we are replicating
that exercise on a global
level among peoples and nations
as we strive to build
the trust, confidence,
and a sense of shared values
and responsibility needed
to address the urgent issues
and threats of our time.
We are all aware that
more and more challenges
from environmental degradation
to drug trafficking
and the spread of
diseases such as HIV/AIDS
have a global dimension.
Through work, travel,
and trips to the store,
we can all see that
trade and communications
are stitching human family
ever more closely together.
These phenomena have also
have to make the 21st century
a very troubling times
for our global village.
Distrust between
cultures and religion
often leads to
violence and has been
aggravated by the
terrorist attacks of 9/11.
Concern is mounting because
of global economic uncertainty
and because the benefits
of globalization
have been shared so unevenly.
Confidence in markets has
been dealt a further blow with
a series of corporate
scandals in the United States
and the gathering feeling that
markets by themselves cannot
respond to the real needs of
society or provide the public
goods that humankind
needs to survive.
In an age of interdependence,
global citizenship
is a crucial pillar
for progress.
In a series of global
meetings and conferences
over the past two
years in particular,
world leaders have
tried to define
what that citizenship means.
They have been trying to build
an inclusive, responsive,
effective, international
system from which
all people can benefit
from and in which all
feel they have a stake.
Shared responsibility
was at the heart
of the declaration
adopted at the Millennium
Summit in September 2000.
160 heads of states
and government
gathered in New York.
All countries came
together not just
to express their general hopes
for peace and development
in the 21st century but
also to give their backing,
their backing to a set of
very specific, time-bound
objectives, which have since
become known as the Millennium
Development Goals.
The goals include reducing
hunger, providing access
to safe drinking
water, and ensuring
universal primary education.
They will be closely
monitored and measured--
how many kids are in
school, how quickly
hunger and extreme
poverty are being reduced.
And we will advertise
the results in such a way
that we hope will
galvanize politics
and policymaking so
that the goals can be
met by the target date of 2015.
Governments faced the first
test of their commitment
to these goals last November
at the World Trade Organization
meeting in Doha.
There, trust was the
main issue on the table--
trust, because the
developing countries
have heard a lot of talk
about free and fair trade
but seen too little,
far too little, of it.
They want to know that
their products will
have an equal chance to
compete in the global market.
That chance is
currently denied them
because of tariffs
on their goods
and because of subsidies
given to their competitors
in the rich countries--
subsidies that I might
add also perpetuate
unsustainable practices in
farming, transport, and energy
use.
The new round of negotiations
agreed to at Doha
offers the prospect that
markets will truly be open.
But it is only a promise.
And it is too soon to
say whether that trust
in the trading system
will be achieved.
Only time will
tell, but I think we
need to work hard and press
ahead to open the markets truly
for all countries.
Next came the Monterrey
Conference on financing
for development last March.
That conference was
also an exercise
in recognizing shared
responsibilities.
The conference generated
substantial new pledges
for official
development assistance,
reversing a decade-long
decline, and made good progress
on issues such as debt relief,
investment, and corruption.
Just as important, developed
and developing countries
reached a common
understanding on
their respective
responsibilities
in the pursuit of balanced
and equitable development.
And finally, last month
at the World Summit
on Sustainable Development
in Johannesburg,
global citizenship once
again took center stage.
All leaders committed themselves
to a path of development
and economic growth
that safeguards
resources and ecosystems
for succeeding generations.
Leaders from rich
countries in particular
agreed to reduce their
nations' ecological footprint
on the planet.
Taken together, these
summits and conferences
give us a blueprint, a
blueprint for development
that puts people, not
states, not GDP statistics,
at the center of policy making.
The overriding challenge
now is implementation.
And for that, we shall need
people from all sectors--
the public sector,
private sector,
civil society to forge more
and better partnerships
to implement these schemes.
One of the most welcome
developments at the United
Nations in recent years has been
the steadily growing engagement
of the business community
both in policy forums
and in projects on the ground.
Though the relationship is
not without its difficulties,
there is growing
recognition that we
must move beyond the
politics of confrontation
and that solutions to poverty,
environmental degradation,
and other challenges
can only be found
if the private sector
is involved and is
an effective partner.
More and more
businesses themselves
are coming to recognize how they
depend on international norms
and standards for the conduct
of business on a global scale
and that the United Nations
wide-ranging work in peace
and development has an
impact on how they do.
In 1999, at the World
Economic Forum in Davos,
I introduced the idea
of a Global Compact.
The Global Compact
was based on my belief
that markets and human
well-being can go hand-in-hand.
Over the long run,
human well-being
can be dramatically advanced
by well-functioning markets.
But markets themselves cannot be
sustained if they do not ensure
human well-being.
I asked businesses at
that time to embrace
nine universal principles in
the areas of human rights,
core labor standards,
and the environment
and to enact these principles
within their spheres
of influence and make it part
of their way of doing business.
I picked these
ideas because I was
worried by a severe imbalance
in global rule making.
While there are extensive
and enforceable rules
for economic priorities such as
intellectual property rights,
there are few strong measures
for equally vital concerns
such as human rights
and the environment.
The compact has since become
more than a call to action.
Today, it involves not
only businesses but also
labor federations and
nongovernmental organizations.
It has promoted the
importance of universal values
and encouraged investors to
look harder at opportunities
in the least developed
countries, particularly
in Africa.
The compact has created
a learning forum,
a worldwide academic network
that examines case studies,
trying to determine what
works and what doesn't.
And I am pleased that Sloan
plays an important role
in this forum.
None of this is
meant to is meant
as a substitute for
action by governments
or as a regulatory framework
or code of conduct.
Rather, the compact is
a voluntary initiative,
a platform for
showing how markets
can be made to serve the
needs of society as a whole.
Business may ask why they should
go down this path, especially
if it involves taking steps
that the competition might
not or steps they
feel are rightly
the province of governments.
Sometimes doing what
is right, for example,
[? equity ?] [? efficiency ?]
or creating decent workplace
conditions, is in the
immediate interest of business.
Sometimes we must do
what is right simply
because not to do
so would be wrong.
And sometimes we do what
is right to help usher
in a new day of new
reforms and new behaviors.
We do not want business
to do anything different
from their normal business.
We one business to do
their business differently.
We want them to
continue what they
do but bear in mind these
values that touch all of us.
And dear friends, openness
is the emerging hallmark
of our time.
But we need to make it work.
Otherwise, countries
and peoples might
retreat behind protectionism,
or worst of all,
reject global citizenship
or globalization
in favor of narrow concepts
of national interest
not at all appropriate
for this interdependent
world we live in, for
this global village.
Business is well-placed not
only to generate employment,
investment, and growth
but also to advance
the global citizenship.
Sloan is well-placed to
teach more than economics,
accounting, and finance and
to help define the parameters
of corporate citizenship.
And I am delighted to hear
that your program is already
evolving in that
direction, and there
is a great deal of
enthusiasm for the program
on corporate citizenship.
And the United Nations is
well-placed to promote dialogue
that will build trust and
create the multilateral norms
and frameworks needed to fulfill
our shared responsibilities.
All of us, the private sector,
civil society, labor unions,
NGOs, universities and
foundations, and individuals
like you must come together
in an alliance for progress.
Together, we can and
must move from value
to values, from shareholders
to stakeholders,
and from balance sheets
to balanced development.
Together, we can and must face
the dangers ahead and bring
solutions within reach.
Thank you very much,
and congratulations
to the Sloan community
on this important day.
I will now be happy to
take your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
PRESENTER: Thank you,
Mr. Secretary-General.
I have a number of
questions from the audience,
and perhaps more
will be forthcoming.
But let me pose one for you.
Do you see a link between
corporate responsibility
and corporate citizenship
on the one hand
and the gulf between haves
and have-nots on the other?
Do companies have
a positive role
to play in creating
a sustainable future?
ANNAN: I think from what I have
said this morning it is clear
that I see a very important
role for the corporate world.
And I think corporations
that respond and react
to these norms do
make a difference
in the communities
and the societies
in which they operate.
Corporations and the
leaders of corporations
are often very
important personalities
in their own communities and can
influence policy and decision
making by governments
and help steer laws
in the right direction.
But they also make a difference
in the day-to-day lives
of the individual.
Corporations don't have
to wait for governments
to pass laws for them to know
that their productions should
not pollute the water that
produces fish for the village.
They need not wait
for governments
to pay a decent wage.
They need not wait
for governments
to try and train their
people and give them--
take the question of HIV/AIDS.
Corporations have done fantastic
things around the world.
Volkswagen [? to ?]
Brazil, for years,
watched its good managers
contract the disease
and die off.
And it took the
decision, we are going
to do something about this.
Came up with a program of
education and treatment
for their managers
and their families
and then begin to see these
creative men and women live on,
continue to deliver
to their company,
and passing the message onto
their families and communities
how to protect themselves.
So the role of corporations
in the issue of development
and their society is
extremely important.
And some are doing extremely
well [? nowadays ?] [? at ?]
[? this ?] to look at what
works and what doesn't.
And corporations do have a role.
PRESENTER: Thank you.
Another question
from the audience
is, what can we at MIT,
at Sloan, and those of us
assembled do in particular
to help realize or advance
the Global Compact Initiative?
ANNAN: I think you're already
on the right track by training
your students and discussing
the Global Compact
Initiative with them.
And I'm sure you
also have a chance
to advise many
corporations, and you
would be able to expose them to
this and talk to them about it.
I've had the chance of meeting
some of the Sloan Fellows
in New York, and
I've been struck
by how enthusiastic they are.
And I know that quite a
few of your professors
are also working on
the Global Compact.
And so I think apart
from teaching it here,
by the learning
forum, and what we
are going to put on the
web to share with others
becomes an important way
of spreading the word.
The other thing
that we are doing
is a learning forums
that we've introduced
where, for example,
corporations can come together
to discuss what their
responsibilities are
and what their posture should
be if they find themselves
operating in areas of conflict.
What is expected
of corporations?
Whom should they
turn to for advice?
And how do they work
together to cope?
And all this, I think,
is going to be extremely
helpful for corporations.
And I'm extremely happy
that US corporations are
beginning to join the compact.
We've had tremendous
response from Europe,
from Latin America, Asia,
and elsewhere in Africa.
Recently, Hewlett-Packard
has joined.
Pfizer is coming on board.
And I expect many
more will join.
PRESENTER: What
responsibilities do
American corporations
in particular
have in the global community?
Do you see a special
responsibility because of--
ANNAN: Well, I
think, today, it is
business and these corporations
that have become the main motor
for the creation of wealth.
They have technology.
They have money.
And they have management.
And they also have
a global reach.
In some ways, a cooperation is
understood faster and better
than governments that we
do live in a global world.
And they work across borders.
And they also know
that in doing that you
need to have some rules.
And I think the corporations
that operate around the world
should see their role not only
as a New York-headquartered
or Silicon Valley-headquartered,
but they should try and also
lift the people in the countries
in which they are operating
and also help the
societies by passing
on some of the
knowledge and some
of the technology
and the training.
Where they fail to do
this, they inadvertently
become part of the
conflict or the problem.
We've seen this.
I can give you an example.
Look at what is happening
in Nigeria with Shell, where
the villages around the
oil production sites
feel they have seen nothing
of the benefits that accrue
from exploitation of their oil.
The money goes to the
central government.
The shareholders
take their profits,
and they see nothing and
continue to live in squalor.
I think it was two or
three months ago when
a group of women demonstrated
and took over one of the site.
And now Shell has indicated
it is going to help them,
and it is going to
put some money back.
And in fact, even if it is not
direct responsibility of Shell,
in a way, it could have
pressure the governments.
Said, don't you think we
should be doing something
for the villages around here?
Can we pull together
and do something?
These kinds of
gestures go a long way.
And I know some
companies have done it.
And I would urge others to
do that-- not only train
the local people,
pass on technology,
but ensure that we spread the
benefits a little bit more.
PRESENTER: I have a
one-word question,
which I think we'd
all be pleased
if you would address briefly.
And that question is--
Iraq?
[LAUGHTER]
ANNAN: I thought I was
going to get away without--
PRESENTER: Now, hold on.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNAN: --answering.
PRESENTER: It's not a
perfect [? scream, ?] no.
ANNAN: No, Iraq, obviously,
is a very topical issue.
And it's a very difficult
issue for all of us.
And the UN has been involved
with this problem for over 12
years now.
And the inspectors, as
you know, were withdrawn
from Iraq in December '98.
And since then, we've not
had inspectors back in Iraq.
Earlier this year,
I got a letter
from the Secretary-General
of the Arab League
saying that Iraqis
would want to sit
with you to discuss the
return of inspectors
without conditions.
So we arranged to meet.
That was, I think,
in February or March.
We met three times this year.
The last meeting was in Vienna.
We seem to be inching forward
but no real breakthrough
or progress.
And then the General Assembly
met on the 12th of September.
And at that time,
the US government
had become very focused
on the Iraq issue.
I spoke, and
President Bush spoke.
We both demanded Iraq to comply.
In my statement, I
made several point.
But there are two I would want
to share with you, arguing
that any country
when attacked has
an inherent right of
self-defense under Article 51
of the UN Charter.
But when that country decides
to deal with a broader
threat to international
peace and security,
the approval and support
of the Security Council
is required, that we need to
have that basic understanding.
Otherwise, we will face major
difficulties down the line.
So we were all delighted
when President Bush
spoke and informed
the world that he
is going to refer the Iraq
issue to the United Nations.
I also indicated to the council
that in such situations,
they would also have
to have the will
and live up to the
responsibilities.
The Security Council,
you know what
has happened in the Congress.
And so I'm not going
to comment on that.
But in the Security
Council, there
is a debate going on now
as to the circumstances
under which the inspectors
should be sent back.
There is a sense that
the disarmament regime
will need to be strengthened.
The inspectors would need to be
strengthened so that we don't
repeat the errors of
the past, and they
can go in with a strengthened
hand and get their work done.
My sense is that that
resolution will be passed.
There's still lots of
discussions and negotiations
going on.
And I expect the council
to send in the inspectors
with their strengthened regime
with a demand that Iraq should
perform and with the request
that the inspectors should
report back should
Iraq fail to do so.
And if Iraq were
to fail to do so,
I suspect the council will
indicate the consequences
that Iraq will
have to face up to.
There has been a suggestion that
maybe even in this resolution
there should be the
phrase, "if Iraq fails,
all necessary means
must be used,"
which is a code phrase
for military action.
But I think the member states
want a two-stage approach.
Send in the inspectors.
If they get into trouble,
if it fails, come back,
and we will pass the
second resolution.
So this is where we are.
And I expect that within
the next week or two
the council will have acted.
The Chief Inspector Hans Blix
and his team are ready to go.
They met with the Iraqis and
discussed the practical aspects
of resumption of their work.
But they are waiting
for the council
to act so that if there
are new instructions,
they can factor it
into their work.
And of course, all the member
states will work together.
And my plea to the council is
that they should work in unity.
From experience, it is
only when the council
is united that they have
the greatest impact.
And I hope and trust
that the council will
be able to manage
this process in a way
that we keep the unity of
the member states together.
We keep the USA in the fold
working with the Security
Council not just for today but
for tomorrow and the day after.
Thank you very much.
PRESENTER: Thank you,
Mr. Secretary-General.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
That was extraordinary.